bonjour à tous ça fait plusieurs années
que je collecte des histoires d'inconnus
avec destin hors du commun des hommes et
des femmes qui ont on nous a pas parlé à
l'étoile mais dont la petite histoire
est entré en collision avec la grande et
en faisant ses recherches j'ai découvert
des récits de vies extraordinaires comme
celui par exemple de souto mouyama gucci
alors ce doublé magoichi c'était un
homme d'affaires japonais qui se
trouvait à hiroshima en 1800 1946 1945
excusez moi le 6 août 1945 exactement ce
qui n'était pas le meilleur jour pour
être à hiroshima puisque c'est ce jour
là qu'une bombe atomique est tombée sur
la ville et faisant malencontreusement
140 mille victimes
70% des bâtiments furent détruits mais
est soutenu par 20 à s'abriter et ils
survécu alors il subit pas mal de
brûlures mais il ya des camps même à ses
enfants pour rentrer chez lui trois
jours plus tard pour retourner au
travail et chez lui c'était à nagasaki
et donc du coup il retourne autres il
retourne au bureau et là ses collègues
le harcèle de questions
évidemment ce qu'il a vu puisque c'était
quand même la première fois qu'une bombe
atomique tomber sur des civils donc là
il explique ce qui s'est passé le flash
lumineux les immeubles qui se sont
évaporés devant lui et son bâton est
assez dubitatif d'ailleurs parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un peu gros comme
excuse pour parler bosser et à ce moment
précis une deuxième bombe atomique tombe
sur nagasaki effet cette fois soixante
dix mille morts mais dessous tomou
survie et il mourra 65 ans plus tard en
2010 à l'âge de 93 ans
c'est la seule personne reconnue par le
gouvernement japonais comme ayant
survécu à deux bombes atomiques
est ce assez c'est exactement le genre
d'histoire que j'ai pu découvrir et
partager avec les gens et en
retranscrivant serré si je me suis
aperçu qu'il y avait certes un fil
conducteur celui par exemple des gens
qui ont changé le monde juste parce
qu'ils ont osé agir penser différemment
et en mai exemple préférer solide jadad
baillargues
alors daniel c'était un jeune garçon de
16 ans en 1979 il vivait près du fleuve
brahmapoutre en inde et un jour il est
marqué par une scène terrible y voit une
centaine de reptiles mort sur un banc de
sable qui se trouve sur le fleuve et là
il décide de faire quelque chose parce
que cette vision le narc profondément il
contacte les autorités forestières et là
on lui explique qu'il n'ya pas grand
chose à faire parce que le banc de sable
est trop aride trop stérile et aucun
homme ne pourra pousser alors il dit
qu'il ya quand même essayer et il
commença à planter des bambous sur ce
banc de sable et après quelques années
de travail acharné
là où il n'y avait rien du tout il
réussit à faire pousser une bambouseraie
et un comme ça marche plutôt pas mal
l'idée c'est de planter des vraies armes
et dix ans plus tard il a créé une forêt
là où il n'y avait rien du tout quelques
années auparavant une forêt dans
laquelle vont venir s'abriter des
animaux des animaux parfois disparition
des rhinocéros des tigres est
aujourd'hui plus de 30 ans après le
début de ses travaux jadhav a réussi à
créer une jungle 2 500 hectares plus
grande que central park et cette jungle
accueille aujourd'hui chaque année une
centaine d' elephant peau d'éléphant et
c'est en craquant ses éléphants que le
ministère des forêts a découvert
l'oeuvre de jaden et ils ont commencé à
l'aider en 2008 l'idée de jade avait été
folle mais elle était bonne et elle a
fini par être soutenu il faut parfois du
temps
alors déjà eu un impact énorme sur sur
l'environnement mais parmi ses héros
oubliés de l'histoire il y en a certains
qui ont parfois sauver des milliers de
personnes c'est notamment le cas
d'ignace c'est my boys il ya semmelweis
était un médecin hongrois qui les lie au
19e siècle et faut savoir que dix
neuvième siècle parfois les femmes
préféreraient accoucher dans la rue
plutôt qu'à l'hôpital parce que le taux
de mortalité avoisiner les 20 % dans les
hôpitaux
le coupable était une maladie
infectieuse la fièvre puerpérale et on
pensait à l'époque qu'elle était
incurable
on avait juste accepter qu environ une
femme sur cinq mouret rouge c'est un peu
le côté est du coup c'est là
qu'intervient il ya semmelweis en 1846
il est nommé à la tête d'une grande
clinique autrichienne et il est bien
décidé à éradiquer ce fléau
et là il va commencer à mettre des
éléments corrélation et il va
s'apercevoir que le taux de mortalité
dans son service c'est directement lié
au fait que les médecins qui s'occupent
des femmes enceintes
pratique aussi des autopsies donc ils
vont tripoter les cadavres avant
d'accoucher les femmes il faut savoir
qu'à l'époque le concept de microbes
n'existe pas donc le lien n'est pas
évident à faire mener ignace va avoir
une intuition va se dire que il doit y
avoir une sorte de substance cadavérique
qui émane des corps et que les médecins
transmettent aux femmes
ils arrivent à avoir cette idée
révolutionnaire est folle il a demandé
aux médecins de se laver les mains avant
d'examiner les patientes et là le taux
de mortalité va passer de 18 à 1,3 pour
cent donc c'est un succès énorme
mais contre toute attente il se met la
communauté scientifique à dos pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que
déjà les médecins considèrent que sa
méthode n'est pas scientifique mais
plutôt superstitieuse ville sait pas
exactement pourquoi est ce que le fait
de se laver les mains éviter la maladie
la deuxième raison c'est que en
acceptant cette méthode les médecins
reconnaissent d'une certaine manière
qu'ils ont contribué à
tuer des milliers de patientes alors du
coup il n'est assez soutenue par le
gouvernement mais il est quand même
maîtrisé par ses collègues et il a très
mal cette situation
il va faire une dépression nerveuse et
il va finir ses jours dans un hôpital
psychiatrique
le cas est tellement injuste qui la
donne est sûrement un effet
psychologique l'effet semmelweis qu'ils
aient cette tendance qu'on a rejeté une
idée nouvelle
si elle bouscule nos habitudes même si
elle est payée par les faits ironie du
sort quelques années plus tard
ignace et mme weiss sera mangée par la
science qui va découvrir l'existence des
microbes
l'idée dinia c'était bizarre à l'époque
mais elle était bonne et a fini par être
acceptée pour parfois du temps l'homme
dont je vous parlais à présent à jouer
un rôle encore plus important puisqu'il
a souri le monde
stanislav petrov stanislas petrov était
un officier russe dont vous n'avez sans
doute jamais vu le visage mais qui a
probablement donc sauver vos vies en
1983 il était affecté à une tâche très
importante il s'occupait de la
surveillance de l'espace aérien russe et
donc ils détecter les éventuelles
attaques de missiles américains et un
jour et par son écran il voit cinq
missiles arrivait en direction de la
russie
qu'at il a juste appuyé sur un gros
bouton rouge pour alerter ses supérieurs
qui envoie une contre attaque immédiate
et plonge le monde dans une guerre
nucléaire globale à la y réfléchisse dit
qu'il allait venir de l'humanité au bout
du doigt et du coup ils hésitent à
quelque chose qui cloche
il ya trop peu de missiles par rapport à
l'arsenal militaire américain qui est
énorme
et en plus de ça il ya un radar au sol
qui ne confirme pas les observations du
satellite
du coup stanislav décide de dire à ses
supérieurs que c'est une fausse alerte
au bluff parce qu'il en sait rien du
tout en fait
les plus gros coup de pub de l'histoire
et la suite lui a donné raison puisque
c'était un blog dans le système
c'est dire qu'on est passé à sa de la
fin du monde
parce que l'officier russe a décidé
d'éditer un peu et pourrait dire qu'il a
été traité en héros exactement il a
plutôt été soupçonné de traîtrise il a
été poussé vers la sortie de l'armée il
faut attendre quinze ans pour que ses
collègues décrivent dans dans ses
mémoires ce qu'il avait vu ce jour là et
que l'histoire de stanislas soit connue
du public
du coup depuis il a été décoré honoré
par les nations unies notamment et quand
on lui demande s'il se considère comme
un héros et dit qu'il a juste fait son
boulot quand même une pure phrase de
hauts entre nos l'idée de stanislav
était risqué mais elle était bonne et
elle a fini par être reconnue faut
parfois du temps comme dans les comics
stanislav un alter ego négatif un homme
qui a bien failli détruire le monde à
lui tout seul
tomasz milliers il a plutôt sympa sur la
photo de mass media est un chimiste
américain qui travaillait en 1911 pour
general motors travaille sur le problème
des moteurs à combustion qui frappe et
qui faisait du bruit et en travaillant
sur le problème ni de lait découvre
qu'en mettant du plomb dans l'essence
les moteurs tournent de façon beaucoup
plus fluide et beaucoup plus silencieuse
c'est un succès international general
motors a écoulé cette essence point b à
des millions de litres le seul petit
souci c'est que le plomb est un poison
violent
donc ils se retrouvent répandue dans
l'atmosphère en masse et il faudra
attendre le début des années 2000 pour
que l'essence plombé soient retirés du
commerce
donc on savait déjà à l'époque qu'elle
était dangereuse la santé publique
commence à ressentir même thomass ni de
l'est souffrent d'effets secondaires
mais ça handicape se laver les mains
avec son essence devant les journalistes
pour montrer qu'elle est inoffensive
aspirer sens du marketing et pour se
rattraper
qui décide de se plonger dans un autre
problème celui des frigos qui fuit parce
qu'à l'époque quentin trillaud fuyez les
gens mouraient du gaz toxique a
interdites rigaud et l'anglais c'est de
mettre au point une alternative et il va
créer le fréon le premier des cfc
chlorofluorocarbures et tout marche à
merveille il inhale du fréon devant les
journalistes parce qu'il a de la suite
dans les idées pour l'axé défensif
il faudra attendre les années 70 trente
ans après la mort de billets pour
connaître les traits effet des cfc
vêtements
nos micros on a découvert un gros trou
dans la couche d'ozone par la faute de
thomas singer il a un peu fait le trou
dans la couche d'ozone à lui tout seul
l'idée de me doubler les idées denis
goulet semblait bonne mais elle était
catastrophique et ça aussi pour le
savoir il faut du temps parfois
alors pour attirer des talents de soins
batteur de ces histoires la première
c'est que si vous avez la possibilité de
déclencher une guerre nucléaire il me
réfléchir avant de le faire si c'est
possible mais au-delà de ça il ya l'idée
qu'une personne seule peut avoir un
impact énorme sur le reste du monde sans
être riche célèbre plus abordés par
suffit parfois d'oser penser
différemment alors toutes ces idées que
vous préférez mettre de côté parce
qu'elles sont trop forts trop risqué ou
trop bizarre laisser leur une chance si
elles sont bonnes le temps le rendra
justice merci